and right now you say kikuchi hoping to
follow in the footsteps of marco
gonzalez and taiwan walker marcus simeon
with a six-game hitting streak leading
off at short the stretch and the pitch
fastball swing at a miss for strike
three and there's one away and you say
strikes out the first batter that he
faces marcus simeon with a good fastball
down and in and there's one away for the
a's here in the top of the first inning
nice start the athletics need a victory
they got the right guy on the mound and
mike fires as we told you in his last 26
starts
with the athletics he is 13 and 1.
and that'll bring up catcher austin nola
1-0 delivery is bounce left side
sprawling to his left in the dirt
chapman gets up throws off the bag but
olson makes the tag on nola going by a
good play on both ends
so two up and two down and
that'll bring up center fielder kyle
lewis the wind-up and the 2-1 decals
swinging the broken back ground ball
skips off the top of the mound in behind
second up with the ball simian the throw
to first no chance to get kyle lewis
nine game hitting streak for kyle lewis
that'll bring up jose
marmalejos
now the 2-2 pitch to marmaleo's here it
is and an off-speed fish is set in the
center field a long run for laureano
goes into a slide and he makes the catch
a good play by ramon
got a good read on a dying fly ball
towards short center
and into the slide and took it off the
grass so marmalaos flies down and now
here's sean murphy hayes with the first
base runner one pitch here from kikuchi
and here comes swung on and hit up the
middle shed long backhands flips to jp
crawford throws and that's a double play
are you kidding that was gorgeous shed
long going towards left field flipped it
to jp coming across the bag he got up in
the air through a one hopper to evan
white dug it out for the double play
inning over wow
that was special
that is one of the best highlights
you're gonna see that'll do it for the
a's in the third we go bottom three here
t-mobile park no score age and the
mariners
in the bottom of the third a scoreless
game but kyle seeger standing in
with the bases loaded
j.p crawford it's almost halfway to home
at third here's a pit swung on line
drive up the middle base hit here comes
crawford nola touches third he's coming
around the throw to third for lewis it
is
got him he came off the bag
and both runs score
so crawford scores nola
scores and lewis is thrown out trying to
get to third that'll do it for the
mariners they get it done with two two
outs here put two on the board it's two
nothing mariners two nothing mariners
that was bill miller explaining to the
oakland folks that that run does count
both runs through count
two nothing mariners will be back right
after this
so they will not go with the replay
review the tag applied on the knee in
time sends us to the fourth two runs in
for the mariners and they lead to
nothing so davis at second biscotti is
it first and sean murphy is coming up
pitch 2-2 swinging i'm missing a
breaking ball down and in
big strikeout for kikuchi
one down here in the sixth that's his
eighth strikeout
so you're a simeon oh for two with two
strikeouts miranda's two is nothing
davis at second biscotti's at first one
two here to simeon right hand hitter
pits swing on and miss struck him out
fastball running away from him
at 96.
that's nine strikeouts for kikuchi his
career best is ten
and he is looking good tonight trying to
pitch his way out of trouble
there's matt chapman fly to right a
strikeout swinging
gucci long look takes a deep breath he
comes set
two out two on
three two pitch runners go the pitch
swung on bounce to third sega retreats a
step steps into the throw throws over in
time to retire chapman kicucci pitches
out of it here in the sixth inning no
runs two hits no errors two left we go
bottom six it's the mariners leading the
ace two nothing
two away runner at second
right hand hitting chad pinder the
second baseman second baseman shading up
the middle
and the pitch swung on and hit to the
gap in right center on the run is moore
along with lewis and that baby is gone
home run for chad pinder the other way a
tremendous drive and suddenly the tables
have turned and the azip tied at a two
pender with his first long ball of the
year
as he hangs in against margot vicious
and klaus went out to right center and
he is f2 on
and davis coming up runners get their
leads the stretch and the pitch on the
way to davis swung out and a fly ball
into left field going back toward the
corner marmillos well in front of the
warning track he's there to make the
catch and that will retire the side we
go to the bottom of the ninth annie
o'connor run will do it mariners have
two outs here in the bottom of the ninth
inning still with the bases loaded and
that will leave it up to shed long
to two
a miss he struck him out what a job by
soria
robbie grossman will come off the bench
and he will bat here for sean murphy
two balls and a strike on grossman
always a good eye at the play tough out
and the pitch basketball stroke to the
right center field that gets down it's
in the alley it's all the way to the
wall the a's have taken the lead kepp is
home the ball sticks under the rubber
they said dead ball but grossman keeps
on running and he's all the way to third
base
it's an rbi triple off the bench for
robbie grossman at a 3-2 oakland lead
and this is going to force the umpires
to get on the horn of new york
so it's going to be a double
and an rbi for robbie grossman and now
here comes matt chapman
the one-two pitch here to chapman alta
villa deals hey did go try to check a
swing that'll do it strikes out chapman
damage done though so two outs now
here's the tough jp crawford and the
one-two breaking ball got him on the
slider the wipeout ends it for the a's a
save for hendricks a win for soria the
a's are 2-0 and extra readings this year